The question,
why are some Americans,
people in the world homophobic,
why do they fear the gay and why did
they oppose,
at least in America so strongly,
gay marriage,
gay unions.
I am not convinced that that many people
really have a problem with gay marriage.
I think there are some people who
absolutely hate and fear the gay and are
very opposed to the gay marriage.
I think it has become a consistent and
dependable fundraiser to where if every
homosexual person in America said,
okay,
we're awful,
we have a bad lifestyle and will slither
under the rock that we,
that we should be living under and we'll
never asked to be married again,
so we'll just take our queer assets and
scuttled back into the slimy shadows
where we belong with the slugs.
They would lose a major fundraising tool
and people in the room would go,
no,
no.
Come back queer marriage.
Want to get married?
Guy,
we need you in the Bible belt.
We need you in South Carolina,
Arkansas,
Florida,
Texas.
To raise the bucks because Islamophobia
only goes so far,
but hating the gay.
That one always runs that one.
Always performs,
so you'll always,
you'll always have that,
you know,
up for debate.
What makes people fear the gay and gay
marriage is because you're giving these
people equality and that's the biggest
fear that people with power have that
you'll get some two people get married.
To me,
the whole contract is completely insane.
I live in the state of California.
If I married some Nice Gal and we got
divorced by law,
does she get half of my record
collection was no way.
She might after I get done with a
chainsaw,
but she's not getting my ramones first
pressing.
Oh No,
no.
She's not getting my Bob Ludwig mastered
version of houses.
The holy high.
I think not.
She can go on Ebay and overpaid like I
did for her own copy.
So marriage for me is I love to go to
weddings,
but I don't want to be married,
but if two people are crazy enough to be
that in love with each other,
that's a great thing.
Give them a break.
Lights really short.
Let him have a little happiness.
There's two men,
they're married,
they're in a house.
Houses are.
No,
it doesn't smell any different,
it doesn't look any different than the
lawn looks fantastic,
but a gay,
if you don't want to,
gay marriage and don't have one.
Same thing with abortion.
No woman wants to have an abortion,
but they gotta have the right to have
one safely without any.
Your opinion does not matter here and so
in,
in this century there's going to be gay
marriage is going to be okay in a more
than half of the United States,
but we used to have slaves,
so that's why we have amendments to the
constitution,
so it has wiggle room.
I think that gay marriage is already
covered under the first amendment,
so I,
I think this conversation's over to
where there shouldn't be against
anything against the law about two men
or women getting married.
It always breaks down to a religious
thing and they'll tell you,
well know they have all the equality
they need and Rara.
Wow.
Okay.
Then are you,
are you,
are you one of those radical Christian
as well?
I am.
That has nothing to do with it.
It it,
it kind of does a lot,
and so that's it.
Basically you have ignorance and you
have hatred.
What a lot of these people don't
understand is they are surrounded by the
gay,
you know,
they got gays in their family.
At thanksgiving I was at,
I went to an all boys school and I had
gay bosses as a kid growing up.
I lived in Washington DC,
which is just a lot of gay people.
My mom had gay friends.
I,
I got it,
I understood it.
I never feared it.
You know,
my,
my Boston high school at the movie
theater with this was this amazing man
of Portuguese descent with incredible
hair who's like a fantastic old school
and like,
like character actor,
Oldschool Queen,
like,
you know,
his name was Bob on Saturday nights he
reverted to Roberta.
Roberta,
yes.
And like I,
I spent high school with this guy every
Saturday night at the movie theater.
We had the best time and if,
if my uptight friends from my suburban
prep school could have seen who I was
hanging out with,
I don't know what they would have
thought.
So I had no problem with the gay,
but it also gave me good Gaydar and in
high school,
well we all hit like ninth and 10th
grade,
whatever.
I realized like we've got gay,
we have at least two gay teachers and
I've got gay gay peers.
There's gay students.
One guy's Kinda like,
you know,
a mini Dick Cheney's that are just
keeping it to himself.
One guy like,
yeah,
you're gay and you're,
you know,
you're,
you're okay with it,
you know,
he's keeping it to himself.
And this is one poor guy who was like,
you know,
gay right now.
And he hit 10th or 11th grade and like,
Hello September at all.
Like,
no,
because I just saw what was gonna happen
to him and we had some really bad
teachers there and one teacher would
make fun of him,
made fun of his name and turned it into
an anti gay slur.
So that teacher basically greenlighted
him if you know the term,
basically a green light of the guy for
is a death warrant because once the
teacher can do that,
that means you can do that.
This is not good leadership that
teachers should have never as an adult
with a bunch of stupid high school
students,
me being one of them should have never
okayed that and by the end of the school
day,
this guy had his head put in the toilet.
He was a dorm kid.
We had a dorm at the school for post
grads and kids who live far from home
and he got teased enough to where he
locked himself in his room and tried to
kill himself by slashing his wrists.
Thankfully he did not succeed,
but at Christmas break he left.
He never came back.
His name was never mentioned in the
school again,
ever.
Not by any teacher ever.
He never happened.
And that politicized me.
That made me Auntie homophobe.
I don't know how you say it,
but you know,
gay rights to me is it's civil rights
and it when I see racism,
which I encountered having it being done
to me as a kid from the sixties and
Washington DC.
When I see homophobia,
it's Kinda like,
it's that straw that breaks the camel's
back.
And I'm the camel.
I,
I go hard against it real hard,
real loud,
real flagrantly,
real right now.
And so what you combated in America is a
lot of undereducated people who have
some idea that Christianity is about
beat up on the gay.
A lot of people just like to hate and a
gay person even though you're surrounded
by them.
And I,
as I,
as I tell my audiences that show,
they go dig it.
There was gay cavemen,
you know,
it gets your head around that.
There was like big hairy men from
millions of years ago going like,
Hey,
let's,
you know,
let's go hit the bushes and like see
what's up.
You'll gay pirates case,
Mri,
k everything.
And that's how it is.
Why some people can't absorb and accept
and deal with that information.
It's too bad.
I believe things are getting better.
I think homophobia is an endangered
species in America as long as I'm around
it is.
And I know I'm not the only person
pushing against him.
So.